hey guys I'm gonna give you five tricks
to make intermittent fasting work faster
okay okay number one potassium potassium
is the most important mineral to fix a
problem with insulin which is behind
weight in memory issues and
cardiovascular and so many other issues
so the reason why people do intermittent
fasting is to fix those things but if
you fix insulin you will speed things up
and you can't do it unless you have a
sufficient amount of potassium our
normal amounts that we need per day is
forty seven hundred milligrams that's a
lot so unless you're doing large salads
or enhance your diet with potassium you
may not hit even your minimum
requirements so potassium is a real
secret mineral to actually speed up
things okay now number two over eating
so a lot of people when they're doing
intermittent fasting they're doing like
two meals a day right and then what
happens is they gorge themselves so much
they stuff themselves because they they
have this idea that oh my gosh I'm not
going to be able to eat I'm only gonna
eat one more it's kind of like a
survival mode when in fact you have a
window if you want to get to like an
eight hour window or even a four hour
window what you can do that's your
eating window it'd be much more
important to let's say you ate in a four
hour window let's say you ate at twelve
and then at four okay so you and you
just can't seem to get enough of those
that food in there to keep your calories
high enough right
so what you do is this is what I do
sometimes I'll have right in the middle
of between twelve and four like at 2:00
I'll consume most of my salad and greens
so that way I have time to digest it
until I eat another meal
you're not going to spike insulin too
much with the with a salad compared to
other things by the way but I'll have my
huge salad right in the middle of two
meals that way I kind of spread it out
but it's still within the four hour
window alright but just don't over eat
especially too many fats because it's
gonna you're gonna feel too stuffed but
in the beginning as you're transitioning
over you do need to add a little bit
more fat until you fully adapted to the
point where you can switch to your own
body fat and be more sustained
than consume fat to be sustained between
the meals okay number three do it
gradually do not go into in a minute
fasting too fast if you have a blood
sugar issue hypoglycemia you're gonna
crash and burn you're gonna it's going
to be really difficult on your body
so I recommend start with three meals a
day no snacks okay do that until you're
fully comfortable then two meals a day
until you're fully comfortable and then
what will happen you can squish those
two meals in within a four hour period
of time so let's say you get up and you
eat at ten o'clock in the morning and
then you eat at like thanks six and then
what you'll do over time when you get
comfortable then you eat at five and
then you'll start at night and then in
the morning you'll school you'll switch
it to eleven o'clock in the morning and
then eventually twelve and then push it
down to four so you can start to
decrease the time the window of eating
and increase enhance the fasting time
but you have to do it at your own pace
do it to your comfortable until your
body says okay I can push a little bit
longer versus trying to force it on your
body because as soon as it doesn't work
you're going to give up and you're going
to have blood sugar issues when you're
having blood sugar issues you're you're
adding more stress more cortisol more
insulin number for extra sleep you ever
notice when you're stressed and tired
you tend to be more hungry cortisol
increases by 50% if you're not sleeping
and that's gonna raise insulin and knock
you out of fat burning so you want to
get extra sleep if you have to take a
nap that's fine but you want to make
sure you get at least seven to eight
hours of sleep
okay also keep your stress as low as
possible go for long walks very very
important to help you sleep last one is
high intensity interval training this is
one of those workouts where you're
working out like a full body
high-intensity high pulse rate short
duration lots of rest I'll put a video
down there to explain that more but this
type of exercise if you add this to in a
minute fasting you can really increase
growth hormone anti-aging fat burning
everything but the key
make it high intensity short duration
lots of rest so make it twice a week or
three times a week or even once a week
making sure you have a lot of recovery
in between because this can make
everything work even better just make
sure you do your workout just after your
last meal or just before your last meal
or during your window of eating so that
way you don't drop your blood Sugar's
too low if you do it on like completely
no food in early mornings okay so those
are the five tweaks that to enhance the
progress to make this go faster thanks
for watching hey guys the quick Servette
question I want to know what topic you
would like me to do a video on so each
week I'm coming up with different types
of videos but I would rather have you
tell me what you're interested in so I
put a link down below please fill it out